liz is on Facebook what's an appropriate
amount for a gift card to send each of
our five grandchildren for Christmas
I've got grandkids Liz I can't see the
four year old opening up a gift card and
going oh that wouldn't happen would it
so I'm thinking you're like the world's
most boring grandmothers what I'm
thinking a gift card to a grandchild
come on find out what the kiddo wants go
down to toys or them and stock up there
in bankruptcy they need your help I mean
really you know a gift card so but how
much do you spend on your grandkids
enough that you make your children
nervous dad that's just too much it's
too much that's that's when you know you
hit the right limit that's what we're
supposed to do when we're grandparents
were supposed to cause problems
give them sweet stuff full of sugar that
keeps them up in caffeine all night no
that kind of hat this is what
grandparents do this is it you're
supposed to have some fun with this so
but not a gift card yawn the amount
though it would be relative to your
income and relative to the household
income that the kiddos live in and you
don't want to you know you don't want to
go over boundaries I'm joking around but
you do kind of want to make people
nervous because you're being lavishes
your grandbabies and that's assuming
you're out of debt and you have the
money and you're not borrowing the money
to do this but now I'm not sending the
baby gee I mean little kids I don't know
maybe their 20 year old grandkids I
don't know but in that case maybe a gift
cards in order I don't know but I can't
think of anything much more boring than
a gift card for anybody I'm 57 I'm not
sure I want a gift card Kelly don't give
me a gift card you weren't planning to
anyway yeah I know you weren't you
didn't even have it yeah I'm not even on
your list not not your Christmas list
anyway
oh you never know you just never know a
gift card no grandma
come on sugar I am all that's sweet
thank no I'm not she's changing her mind
right here being a DD right here on my
gift-giving well I'll have to check on
my list and see which one you're on so
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]